well,
how are you, cristian cásseres greets you with
his previous news now in
spanish each key measure in the fight
against the coronavirus basically continues to
show a downward trend on
thursday the state reported 592 new
cases and 55 deaths the
hospitalization figures also show a
drop  Of almost 25 percent in a
week, the rate of
positive cases has also dropped again and due to the
progress that is being seen,
Governor Sticks is the one who announced on
Thursday that they will loosen
capacity restrictions in the state of Nevada but
will do so in  stages i heard this as
of monday february 15 capacity limits will
increase to 35% for
most businesses including
restaurants while libraries
museums and aquariums will be able to increase their
capacities to 50% public gatherings
can now be up to 100 people or
a  capacity of 35% of the venue whichever is
less the governor said he would
further relax the limits for that  Coming
March 15,
the new rules will also allow
fans to return to sporting events
like NASCAR races scheduled
for next month. The governor said
20% capacity would be allowed for large sports gatherings, but it
was unclear how many people.
exactly these sporting events will be able to return
in two weeks thousands of students in
pre-k through third grade will
begin some in-person classes
the clark county school district
has new agreements with two unions
to ensure a safe return to
school campuses
thursday  The school district board of trustees
signed the nearly
$3 million plan last night. The agreement
also includes three windows of negotiations. It
also provides
personal protective equipment for each employee, including
masks and sanitizer, and each
employee will be required each month
to  take a test for
corona  virus if the employee tests
positive they must work from home and
not return to the campus until they
present a negative result and
finally we take a look at the
temperatures in our region
another system is expected to approach
tomorrow with the temperatures
reaching the high sixties don't forget
your umbrella as it even anticipates rain
for today and tomorrow night we will have
winds for sunday but no
chance of rain for valentine's day i
'm cristian cásseres and
this is a brief informative from news now
in spanish  happy
[Music]